[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
notre région bonjour je remercie
beaucoup d'être là vous êtes député des
hauts-de-seine porte-parole de
renaissance le mouvement de la majorité
présidentielle et on est ensemble qu'on
en 20 minutes ch pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre aux dons du groupe ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
roland marescq bonjour oriane bonjour
votre potion mode région avait
évidemment parler de ce qu'a dit
emmanuel macron ce week-end il maintient
elisabeth borne à son poste de première
ministre je le cite voyons les refus les
disponibilités qui se sont exprimés lors
des premiers échanges avec les forces
politiques est-ce qu elisabeth bande ça
reste une minute par défaut absolument
pas et ça n'a jamais été le cas à
elisabeth bornes elle a été nommé
premier ministre par le président de la
république
de par ses compétences de par son
expérience à la une carrière
professionnelle très riche elle a une
carrière politique où elle a su mener
des réformes qui étaient des réformes
difficiles et donc aujourd'hui elle à
cette mission qui lui a été
réaffirmée cij plusieurs par le
président de la république auprès de vos
confrères de la fp d'arriver à continuer
à discuter à concerter avec les forces
politiques c'est ce qu'elle fera cette
semaine l'objectif c'est d'arriver à
savoir jusqu'où on peut aller sur par
exemple un accord de gouvernement ce à
quoi sont prêts à s'engager d opposition
et une fois que ce travailleur a été
réalisée proposé au président de la
république
la formation d'un gouvernement qui doit
être un gouvernement d'action parce que
ne l'oublions pas derrière les logiques
qui peuvent apparaître parfois comptable
pour vos téléspectateurs de nombre de
votants vie à des problématiques
extrêmement concrètes comme par exemple
la question du pouvoir d'achat sur
lequel on est tous attendus peu importe
nos groupes nos partis politiques
d'apartheid on va en parler mais ne pas
changer de premier ministre alors que
les urnes ont parlé dimanche dernier ça
peut quand elle donnait le sentiment de
ne pas avoir écouté le message des
français je remarque ça vous rappelle
chapic elisabeth byrne elle a été élu
dans sa circonscription
les français lui ont fait confiance les
habitants du calvados ont des amis
calvados a circonscrit il fabien roussel
robert ménard yannick ado ne disent pas
non à un gouvernement du nom d'union
nationale est ce qu'il faut le faire je
crois qu'on a besoin de créer un
gouvernement de femmes et d'hommes de
bonne volonté et des majorités de
projets et des majorités d'objectifs
donc c'est le travail et je le redis qui
est menée par idc avait deux bornes
regardons ce que nous on veut faire on
veut par exemple tendre vers le plein
emploi on veut engager une transition
énergétique qui se base sur le nucléaire
et sur les énergies renouvelables tout
un tas de points comme ça sur lequel on
doit réussir à converger moi j'invite
sans rentrer dans les noms des uns et
des autres mais toutes celles et ceux
ont envie que la france avance qui comme
nous ont la conviction que les français
ont donné une majorité relative au
président mais à aucun moment on fait le
choix d'une majorité de blocage à
travailler et avancer avec nous vous
parlez de conviction vous venez de
prononcer le mot justement et toutes les
personnes que je viens de citer en des
convictions qu'ils sont assez
différentes des vôtres en réalité demain
vous seriez prêtre par exemple à
soutenir un gouvernement dans lequel
auquel appartient leur assemblée
nationale où des gens proches du
rassemblement national nom et le
président de la république a été
extrêmement clairs là dessus ces
discussions elles sont entamées avec les
partis de gouvernement ceux qui sont
prêts à prendre leurs responsabilités
ceux qui sont prêts à accepter de faire
des compromis aussi parce que dans la
situation dans laquelle on est on
appliquera pas le programme des uns ou
des autres de façon complètement entière
est parfaite de plus le rassemblement
national est pour moi un parti d'extrême
droite je pense qu'il ya une ligne rouge
extrêmement clair on l'a toujours tenus
c'est au coeur de notre adn voilà
maintenant les autres formations
politiques
je pense par exemple au parti socialiste
je pense par exemple aux républicains il
faut qu'on se mette autour de la table
c'est ce que fait la première ministre
est arrivé à savoir quelles sont nos
plus petits dénominateurs communs et ce
sur quoi on peut avancer ensemble sauf
qu'en excluant la france insoumise et
rassemblant nationale vous inscrire les
deux principaux groupes d'opposition ce
que les groupes d'opposition quand le
plus de députés est ce qu'il ya une
forme de mépris par rapport au vote des
français de dimanche dernier non je
voudrais être extrêmement clair on a une
hostilité vis-à-vis des projets des
programmes portés par jean luc mélenchon
l'epa marie par marine le pen on a pas
d'hostilité vis-à-vis de leurs électeurs
moi j'entends un vote qui s'est tourné
vers le rassemblement national qui peut
être un vote désespoir parce que il ya
des vraies problématiques sur le pouvoir
d'achat parce que les services publics
se sont éloignés depuis 20-30 ans il
s'agit pas de juger ou du feu laisser
penser que les gens auraient mal voté ce
serait effectivement extrêmement
méprisant donc écoutons quelles sont ses
attentes les éleveurs ils ont donné un
mandat à 89 députés du rassemblement
national quand elisabeth banjo
d'histoire dit les amendements qui
viennent seulement du rassemblement
national on entendait on en tiendra pas
compte est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi un
manque de respect vis-à-vis du vote des
électeurs non parce qu'on doit on veut
travailler encore une fois pour
l'intérêt de tous les français moi je
suis député de la 13e circonscription
des hauts-de-seine eh bien je j'ai été
élu par mes électeurs mais je considère
l'ensemble des habitants devant tony de
saut de bourg-la-reine de châtenay
malabry qu'ils aient voté pour moi ou
pour mes concurrents lors des élections
etc à tout ce qu'on doit leur répondre
maintenant encore une fois on a une
ligne qui doit être très clair vis-à-vis
de l'extrême droite on l'a redit par
exemple à l'entre-deux tours des
législatives
lorsqu'il y avait des duels qui opposait
la nuit au rassemblement national en
disant pas une voie pour le
rassemblement national nul ce
rassemblement national il ya des
tiraillements entre eux pour savoir
qu'il qui est le premier groupe
d'opposition à vos yeux c'est king chef
de l'opposition aujourd'hui moi j'ai pas
donner des cartons jaunes ou des cartons
rouges ou à faire l'arbitré entre les
groupes des uns ou des autres donc voilà
c'est je rentrerai pas dans ce débat là
je pense que ça intéresse assez peu de
monde mais qu'est ce que vous êtes prêt
vous à parce qu'il ya des discussions
cette semaine dans des discussions il
faut que chacun amène un petit peu
quelque chose qu'est ce que vous êtes
prêts à donner aux républicains au parti
socialiste le parti communiste est au
vert pour qu'ils acceptent de travailler
avec vous est ce que vous êtes prêt à
amender votre programme par exemple le
président de la république a été très
clair à ce sujet la base des discussions
c'est le projet présidentiel pourquoi
parce que emmanuel macron a été réélu
les 10 et 24 avril c'était une victoire
contrairement à ce que certains auraient
voulu laisser entendre et derrière les
français ont choisi de lui donner une
majorité relative certes mais une
majorité tout de même donc le projet
présidentiel c'est la base de ces
discussions et il pourra tête c'est ce
que dit emmanuel macron enrichi ou
amendé sur la base des concertations que
mènera l born ya par exemple deux grands
chantiers qu'on avait ciblé pendant la
présidentielle qui étaient les questions
d'écoles et de santé sur lequel on
assume est de dire on n'arrive pas avec
un projet ficelé de az précisément parce
que l'on doit faire on doit travailler
de façon très concertée avec les
différents élus mais également et
évidemment avec le corps enseignant avec
les médecins pour trouver les meilleures
solutions et donc je crois que là-dessus
dans l'intérêt général on doit pouvoir
réussir à trouver des consensus il ya un
autre chantier aussi c'est la réforme
des retraites est ce que là vous êtes
prêt à l'amender et il ya revoir ce
projet pour justement qu'ils puissent
avoir un large consensus au parlement
même chose on avait également dit sur la
réforme des retraites on n'arrive pas
avec un projet qui est complètement figé
on a un objectif général ya une
philosophie dans cette réforme qui est
d'une part d'avoir un système qui doit
être plus juste et c'est pour ça qu'on
propose une retraite minimum à 1100
euros c'est pour ça qu'on propose de
revoir et notion de pénibilité de
carrières longues et en même temps ce
système il doit être équilibré sur la
durée et doit être pérenne parce que moi
aujourd'hui je travaille pour payer la
retraite de mes parents j'espère que
demain les enfants pourront payer
pourront travailler pardon pour payer la
mienne également et donc et une larme au
début c'était clair il a plein d
emmanuel macron il y avait un report de
l'âge de départ à 65 ans après il est
revenu dessus pendant la campagne ont
finalement les 65 ans c'était pas un
totem aujourd'hui quel peut être le
projet parce que la droite par exemple à
la tient à l'âge légal de départ à 65
ans edouard philippe aussi doit payer
vous allez contenter tout le monde ne
doit pas y avoir effectivement de totem
c'est tout à fait juste parce qu'il faut
garder en tête l'objectif l'objectif
c'est d'avoir cet équilibre c'est
équilibre pardon et donc ça nécessite un
décalage progressif de l'âge de départ à
la retraite maintenant tout ça doit
évidemment être discuté avec l'ensemble
des formations politiques c'est le
principe je crois du parlement tel qu'il
a été élu encore plus peut-être que sur
la mandature précédente
donc voilà vraiment dans une logique de
concertation mais gardons en tête que
les objectifs je crois est né sans fixer
de vous garder en tête qu'il faut décalé
là je n'ai pas on garde en tête qu'il
faut décaler l'âge de départ précisément
pour rendre le système plus pérenne sur
la méthode on en parlait à l'instant
michel barnier le républicain michel
barbier avec lequel vous partager des
convictions européennes
pour être clair je cite dit il faut qu
emmanuel macron change de méthode et de
politique je sais pas ce que veut dire
michel barnier en disant que le
président doit changer de méthode être
politique sur la question de la méthode
des les présidentielles et madame macron
a mis en avant cette nécessaire nouvelle
méthode de discuter plus de discuter
mieux avec les différentes forces
politiques avec les partenaires sociaux
avec les corps intermédiaires avec les
élus locaux c'est ce que on avait comme
volonté et c'est ce qu'on a encore plus
aujourd'hui du fait du vote a été celui
des français
canarie et 19 juin ben non moi je rêve
rappeler à chacun pour dialoguer faut
être deux enfin faut être au moins deux
le président de la république il a
attendu quatre fois la main cette
semaine enfin depuis sept jours une
première fois dimanche soir par la voix
d'elizabeth bornes soir du second tour
des élections législatives puis en
dialoguant avec les différentes
formations politiques mardi et mercredi
et puis une troisième fois lors de son
allocution mercredi soir et encore
dimanche hier auprès de vos confrères de
la fp donc j'entends parfaitement ce que
dit michel barry bah écoutez je l'invite
à venir à la table et à discuter avec
nous pour faire avancer le pays on a
effectivement des convictions communes
par exemple sur la question de l'europe
et pour dialoguer faut être deux mais ça
veut dire qu'il est prêt un changement
de méthode et même à quoi il est prêt à
plus écouter le parlement est-ce que
d'accord il ay fè des concertations mais
dans le quinquennat précédent les
oppositions exemplarité juge devrait
coûter au parlement il a lui même prôné
ce changement de méthode d les
présidentielles avant qu'on connaisse le
résultat des élections législatives donc
en fait tout ça est cohérent maintenant
on doit le mettre en oeuvre charge à
chacun je vais le dire d'y mettre du
sien et de faire avancer ce dialogue
parce qu'encore une fois on est tous
comptables devant nos électeurs
moi c'est ce que je dis aux députés des
autres formations politiques quand on
rentrera en circonscriptions dans
quelques jours et qu'on se sera pas mis
d'accord par exemple sur les questions
de pouvoir d'achat on sera tous
comptables on devra tous l'expliquer on
devra tous expliqué ou retraités que
leur retraite peut-être n'augmentera pas
parce qu'on s'est pas accordé sur
l'indexation des retraites sur
l'inflation pour le mois d'août je crois
que encore une forme on a vraiment
besoin de responsabilité et de de plus
de concertation un mot sur les jours à
venir se pose la question du vote de
confiance et les abeilles borne n'a pas
tranché en tout cas jeudi soir elle n'a
pas dit qu'elle avait tranché est ce que
vous pouvez vous passer d'un vote de
confiance pour entamer de son
quinquennat politiquement parlant je
passe à ce ne serait pas un mauvais
signal j'ai le vote de confiance je le
disais je crois qu'elle l'a d'abord eu
dans sa circonscription en étant réélu
dans un contexte qui était difficile
maintenant c'est à elle est peut-être au
regard des consultations et des
concertations qui amènera les heures et
les jours à venir de prendre sa décision
donc je m'exprimerai pas à sa place très
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça va changer
j'entends par exemple jean luc mélenchon
enfin plus généralement la france
insoumise lorsqu'on a fait des votes de
confiance précédemment est-ce qu'ils ont
estimé que les premiers ministres
étaient le plus légitime est ce que ça a
changé leur comportement leur posture
vis-à-vis du gouvernement pas forcément
donc je crois que voilà ils sont aussi
là dans une forme de tactique de
communication qui s'avère un peu
politicienne python part de la france
insoumise adrien 4 nages en mai qu eric
coquerel serait le candidat de la nuque
pour la commission des finances puisque
cette semaine l'assemblée doit élire ses
commissions vous nous confirmer que la
majorité présidentielle ne prendra pas
part au vote la majorité présidentielle
ne prendra pas part au vote en revanche
et c'est normal ce sera pas à nous de
faire l'arbitré entre les uns et les
autres le rassemblement national la
nuque ce qui arrive ou pas à se mettre
d'accord autour d'un nom peuple un peu
vous importe
l'important pour moi c'est d'avoir
quelqu'un qui soit compétent et
responsable à la tête de cette
commission parce que ça engendre
s'adonnent à la personne qu'il le sera
qui sera président des prérogatives et
des responsabilités qui sont importantes
et donc j'espère qu'on voit là chacun
donc eric coquerel ce sera une bonne
personne j'aurai donc président de la
com je vais donner des notes les uns ou
des autres mais j'espère que chaque
groupe politique d'opposition prendra
ses responsabilités pour présenter un
candidat à la hauteur de la fonction
vous trouvez ça bien que la nuque qui
siège en cas de gros pépin salies
justement pour faire barrage au
rassemblement national sur ce poste
encore une fois c'est leur problématique
intergroupe à eux et c'est pas une
députée de la majorité présidentielle de
porter des jugements sur ces sur ses
calculs la toile a bien compris vous
rester en marge de leur leur querelle
pourtant ce sont vos opposants mais là
même la même façon qu'eux
j'estime qu'ils n'ont pas eu à
s'immiscer dans les problématiques ou
dans les logiques peuvent avoir la
majorité présidentielle ils ont une
question de candidats non une question
mathématique quasi comptable ça a eu la
gérer c'est à eux de la résoudre nous on
respecte ce principe qui est que la
majorité ne prend pas part au vote autre
question à laquelle il va falloir
répondre c'est quelle président ou
quelle présidente pour l'assemblée
nationale vous êtes une toute nouvelle
députée depuis quelques quelques jours
et il ya la bonne pile et va quitter à
quitter le gouvernement pour briguer la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale ce
sera ça serait la première fois qu'une
une femme accède au perchoir tout à fait
alors vous en attendez quelque chose en
matière de gouvernance de l'assemblée
nationale est ce que vous en tant que
femmes et les chaînes député vous
attendez quelque chose de cette élection
alors rappelons d'abord que ya le
burundi mais c'est la candidate qui a
été élu au sein de la majorité
présidentielle des différentes
composantes de la majorité
présidentielle à l'assemblée nationale
pour être notre candidate commune
pourquoi on la lui sera élu demain
présidente de l'assemblée nationale sauf
énorme surprise on l'a pas eue en
premier lieu parce qu'il ya le groupe
privé et une femme on l'a d'abord élu
parce qu'elle est compétente qu'elle a
su montrer lors du mandat précédent sa
capacité de travail c'est avec ap la
cité des coudes quand elle était
présidente de la commission des lois
parce qu'elle a une expérience politique
et en même temps une expérience issue de
la société civile qui je crois en font
un profil particulièrement adapté à la
situation avec qu'on est en train de
traverser donc moi je suis très heureuse
et bien sûr en tant que femme parce que
c'est historique on est une femme qui
boit qui prennent pensée de dieu cela ça
montre sa montre ça peut apporter
quelque chose au fonctionnement de la
vie politique de l'assemblée nationale
je crois que la parité apporte toujours
quelque chose et que le fait d'avoir des
femmes et des hommes apporte toujours
quelque chose puis ça montre qu'on
rentre dans une nouvelle ère on a une
présidente de groupe qui est aurore
bergé on a nos rages l'espère une
présidente de l'assemblée nationale qu'
israël brawn privé et on a une première
ministre qui est élise avait deux bornes
si on nous avait dit ça ya quelques
années on ray pas forcément cru c'est
une vraie avancée donc je pense qu'on
peut largement s'en réjouir puisqu'on
parle des femmes on va parler de l'ipg
puisque la cour suprême américaine a
décidé de supprimer le droit à
l'avortement au robert g a annoncé ce
week-end qu'elle la majorité
présidentielle déposé une proposition de
loi constitutionnelle pour inscrire ce
droit à l'avortement dans la
constitution sauf que dans le précédent
quinquennat vous y est opposée lorsque
la gauche vous demandait de le faire
pourquoi ce revirement le contexte n'est
plus du tout le même ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis
illustre tristement une réalité qui est
que les droits des femmes c'est un
combat qui au fond n'est jamais acquis
et que les avancées ne sont jamais
définitivement acquis c'est en fait une
lutte permanente est ce que les droits
des femmes est ce que le le recours à
l'avortement elle dit vg et mise en
danger aujourd'hui en france non est ce
qu'il pourrait l'être demain oui les
états unis doublant prouver donc ford on
aurait pu dire la même chose et a trois
enfants il ya trois ans vous l'avez
report de cette triste illustration on
prend nos responsabilités et j'espère
que l'ensemble des formations politiques
sans regarder vers le passé sans savoir
qui a déposé la proposition loi mais
vraiment dans l'intérêt supérieur des
femmes et du droit des femmes se
ralliant à cette cause qui est très
importante et qui je crois a transcendé
complètement doit ou devrait
complètement transcendé les clivages
partisans on est de vrais parce que
françois bayrou par exemple quel
président du modem qui est quand même
une composante forte de la majorité se
demande si c'est utile pour le pays en
ce moment que ce que vous dites ne
savent déjà que j'ai pas l'ombre du
dixième du quart d'un doute quant à
l'attachement cas françois bayrou au
doigt des droits des femmes et à
fortiori à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse je voulais être extrêmement
clair mais ne réduit pas qu'il est
contre les jets il demande ou si c'est
le bon moment
d'inscrire dans la constitution si c'est
la priorité françois bayrou vous le
savez est un ovni libre de parole et
c'est bien normal moi je crois que il
n'ya pas à mettre à essayer de savoir ce
qui est par exemple le plus important
entre
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et le pouvoir d'achat c'est extrêmement
différents on a aujourd'hui un contexte
international qui nous rappelle à quel
point il est nécessaire de préserver ces
droits là peut-être que ce n'est pas le
sujet duquel on parle sur les plateaux
télé en ce moment mais pour des femmes
pour un certain nombre de femmes ça
reste quand même leur quotidien c'est un
enjeu extrêmement importante et donc je
crois que si on attend précisément que
ce droit là soit remis en cause en fait
il sera probablement trop tard mais
pourquoi pourquoi vous l'avez refusé ya
trois ans parce que ça venait de la
gauche non pas parce que ça venait de la
gauche parce qu'on était dans un
contexte différent avec ont traversé
aussi des crises qui était très présente
et donc on s'est attelé à autre chose
avait pas ce qui se passe notamment aux
etats-unis aujourd'hui ça suscite
peut-être une forme de prise de
conscience collective et c'est tant
mieux je pense qu'il faut pas
éternellement ressasser le passé
j'entends complètement ces questions là
maintenant regardons l'avenir regardant
quel est l'objectif est l'objectif c'est
de protéger les droits des femmes est ce
qu'en fit dégrade c'est pas aussi
l'américanisation de notre société qui
inquiète l'américanisation de notre
société c'est à dire vous avez relevé
cette tombe deux chocs venus des états
unis après cette décision de la cour
suprême on voit que aux états unis mais
comme dans bon d'autres pays les droits
des femmes parfois recule donc tant
qu'on est en temps calme si je puis dire
en france posons nous regardons comment
est-ce qu'on contraire on peut les
préserver et les sanctuary zh et je le
disais il faut jamais considérer que les
droits qu'on a acquis le sont
définitivement
c'est une lutte et c'est une conquête
permanente aujourd'hui on est en
responsabilité et charge à nous de faire
en sorte qu'ils puissent être préservés
savage le premier texte voté par le
parlement pour que le symbole très fort
c'est une discussion qui doit être mené
avec l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires
et ce sera le fait dans les jours et les
semaines à venir sans aucun doute
d'autant qu'à la question du pouvoir
d'achat évidemment on vous en avait
parlé y aller une tribune dans le
journal du dimanche tribune des
fournisseurs d'électricité des
dirigeants d' angie d'edf de total
énergie qui disent que la flambée des
prix menacent notre cohésion sociale et
politique et impact trop lourdement le
pouvoir d'achat des familles je les cite
est-ce qu'il faut prendre de nouvelles
mesures alors le président de la
république le gouvernement la majorité
dans son ensemble a toujours eu une
seule boussole c'est de protéger les
français et de protéger les français
face à la hausse des prix on a mis en
place le bouclier tarifaire on a mis en
place la remise à la pompe sur le
carburant et donc on doit je crois faire
perdurer ces mesures ça nécessite
d'avoir une majorité pour le goûter et
là encore une fois à chacun de prendre
ses responsabilités
la majorité présidentielle bien sûr mais
également l'opposition il ya deux choses
il ya d'abord un contexte qui est celui
qu'on est en train de traverser a fait
qu'effectivement le gaz en provenance de
russie qui se fait de plus en plus rares
avec des moyens pilotable en europe qui
sont très contraint en france parce que
là une partie des réacteurs nucléaires
sont à l'arrêt de façon plus générale en
europe parce que certains pays ont
décidé dé fermer et puis des ressources
hydrauliques qui sont sous tension du
fait des conditions météorologiques
donc il faut arriver à y répondre de
façon extrêmement rapide ça passe par
les questions de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat avec jean d'évoquer sa passe
aussi par la notion de sobriété il va
falloir consommer moins et consommer
moins le plus rapidement possible à
l'espagne avait lâché à lancer une
concertation pour avoir un grand plan de
sobriété qui concerne les particuliers
mais qui concerne les entreprises qui
concerne les questions résidentiel qui
concerne les plus gros consommateurs et
c'est extrêmement important d'une part
parce que consommer moins et maintenant
c'est ce qui nous permettra de passer
l'hiver et de passer les pointes de
consommation plus facilement dans
quelques mois et puis c'est aussi ce qui
permettra d'arriver à maintenir les prix
le plus bas possible même s'il va
falloir imposer des restrictions
restrictions aux entreprises
restrictions en particulier c'est le cas
dans d'autres pays du monde 2 bien sûr
d'autres pays le font et justement d'où
là ces sites est d'anticiper pour
réfléchir avec eux avant d'arriver à des
impositions qui pourrait être brutal
comment est ce qu'on trouve le meilleur
plan de sobriété possible ou est-ce
qu'on a des marges comment est ce qu'on
peut faire en sorte que chacun d'eux
consomme mois et donc là on a une
responsabilité qui est individuelle et
collective qui est menée avec à se
planquer mené par agnès pannier rien
lâcher donc encore une fois un c'est
vraiment on maintient on soutient le
pouvoir d'achat sur la question des prix
ont lancé un grand plan de sobriété et
puis et une perspective de plus long
terme qui est qu on a besoin d'avoir
davantage de moyens de production chez
nous on ne voit plus dépendants du gaz
russe c'est pour ça que emmanuel macron
expliqué pendant la présidentielle qu'il
fallait que la france soit le premier
pays de l'union européenne est le pur la
première grande nation à sortir des
énergies fossiles parce qu'on voit sauf
que dans le vestiaire vous relancer des
centrales à charbon et à nouer en
tension sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
on voit que ça nous met en tension sur
les prix d'où cette volonté de
développer massivement et les énergies
renouvelables et les centrales
nucléaires ce sera une bonne chose pour
le pouvoir d'achat ce serait une bonne
chose pour le climat et ce serait une
bonne chose pour l'indépendance à
charbon à ce que c'est pas
contradictoire de relancer des centrales
à charbon puisque ça semble être le cas
il ya des centrales quatre volets on
aurait tous préféré ne pas relancer la
centrale à charbon de saint-avold on est
complètement d'accord en revanche on a
quand même une impérative nécessité si
je puis dire c'est de permettre à chacun
d'avoir de l'électricité pour allumer sa
lumière et se chauffer l'hiver prochain
donc s'il ya besoin d'augmenter de façon
temporaire la production d'électricité
la production d'énergie à partir de
charbon il est possible qu'il faille le
faire mais ça ne doit être que
temporaire et ça doit être accompagnée
d'un plan encore une fois de
développement des énergies renouvelables
nucléaire pour qu'on n'ait pas besoin de
le faire dans un deux trois ou quatre on
est question sur votre parti oui deux
des nouveaux ministres du gouvernement
k nommée emmanuel macron sent visé par
des plaintes pour viol et qu'est ce que
selon vous cela dit société notre vie
politique comme une fois moi je crois
personnellement une façon très forte que
on doit se situer dans le cadre du droit
il ya aujourd'hui une la présomption
d'innocence et c'est celle ci qui doit
prévaloir parce que sinon on rentre dans
quelque chose qui à mon avis peut nous
mener très loin à être extrêmement
dangereux on se tient ce cadre là à ce
cadre du droit et en parallèle bien sûr
on accompagne les femmes pour qu'elles
puissent porter plainte on a formé
environ cent mille policiers il ya
maintenant une possibilité de porter
plainte hors des murs donc hors des murs
du commissariat ce qui permet de
recueillir la parole des femmes une
façon voilà plus peut-être plus
confortable si je puis dire ou de
facilité en tout cas c'est ce recueil de
la prise de parole mais dans le tout ça
doit se faire dans le cadre de l'état de
droit dans la question sur votre parti
puisque vous sortez quand même affaiblie
renaissance l'ancien république en marge
de ces législatives est-ce que stanislas
béré ni plus moins pour à la tête du
parti ce parti est en train d'être
refondée c'était la république en marche
il va devenir renaissance celle avec un
nouveau président et un nouveau délégué
du ca stanislas guérini de dire ce qu'il
confirme on sentiment connaissant un
petit peu stanislas sais qu'il a envie
se consacrer pleinement à sa fonction
ministérielle et c'est bien normal et
j'en profite pour saluer le travail
qu'il a mené pendant
trois ans quatre ans je ne sais plus
exactement à la tête de la république en
marche dans des périodes comparées pour
vous il devra laisser sa place à un
français le gouvernement il retombait
avec une nouvelle il a été un excellent
capitaine c'est à lui de dire ce qu'il
sait faire mais on a sion que vous ma
conviction c'est qu'il aura envie de se
consacrer pleinement à sa tâche de
ministres
de garder le nom d' renaissance pardon
c'est opportun de garder le nom de
renaissance que vous aviez lancé avant
les différents on change le nom de la
logique en marche pour devenir officier
naissance et avait conservé de conserver
ce nom bien ce projet oui bien sûr parce
que ça a du sens comme comme terme comme
sémantique et puis ça fait référence
aussi à notre histoire renaissance à
c'était le nom de notre utile aux
européennes ça traduit aussi cet adn
très fort d'attachement aux valeurs et à
l'union européenne qu'on a porté depuis
le début de cette grande aventure en
2016 dont merci moi de région d'avoir
essayé notre invité ce matin
[Musique]